willkommen an der militärakademie wiener
neustadt mein name ist oberst markus
reissner ich bin der leiter der
forschungs entwicklungsabteilung und
heute wollen wir uns in einem neuen
video mit dem einsatz von drohnen im
ukraine konflikt befassen tatsächlich im
rahmen des konflikt verlauf es sind
unsere betrachtungen zwar zum teil auf
den einsatz der landstreitkräfte
konzentriert also panzer aber
holistische raketen interessant ist aber
dass gerade thronen im complete eine
sehr große rolle spielen und das wollen
wir uns heute im detail ansehen zuerst
wollen wir uns ansehen wie man diese
drohnen einteilen kann
es gibt drei klassen von drohnen es gibt
kleinere drohnen wie diese
handelsüblichen chinesischen die
patronen bis zu großen militärischen
thronen die die größe eines
verkehrsflugzeuges haben drohne kann man
einteilen nach gewicht der
leistungsfähigkeit auch in der distanz
auch nach größe beziehungsweise auch ob
es ein flächen modell ist oder mit zum
beispiel wie dieser helikopter mit der
rotoren ausgestattet ist hier habe ich
das noch einmal im detail dargestellt
also klasse 1 und 150 kilogramm das kann
man noch mal unterteilen micro mini oder
small oder auch taktische drohen an der
kasse 250 kilogramm aufwärts mit
natürlich entsprechende reichweite von
bis zu 200 kilometern
darüber hinaus gibt es natürlich die
klasse 3 also drohnen über 600 kilogramm
und wie zb das system mail so medium
altitude long endurance vergleichbar mit
dem bekannten predator und reaper
drohnen und amerikanischen streitkräfte
oder auch hier als beispiel diese global
hawk drohne die was die größe eines
verkehrsflugzeuges hat und von usa und
nato eingesetzt werden gerade diese
drohne hat eine hohe bedeutung denn wenn
wir uns ansehen dass es laufend
aufklärungsflüge stattfinden vom
bemannten und unbemannten flugzeugen
entlang der grenzen der ukraine zu sehen
wir zum beispiel hier den einsatz und
akku vier tonnen im schwarzen meer zur
aufklärung was in der russischen
streitkräfte im süden der ukraine
was auch noch bedeutungsvoll ist ist der
zusammenhang zwischen der größe der
drohne und der leistungsfähigkeit je
kleiner die drohne desto billiger und
desto geringer der technische aufwand
und wie größere drohne natürlich desto
größer der aufwand und auch die möglich
hier ist auch dann der unterschied von
der reinen aufklärungsdrohne zu einer
bewaffneten drohnen zu sehen hier im
bereich der kleineren drohnen das kann
also auch nicht nur ein handelsübliches
modell sein sondern das kann zum
beispiel auch über crowdfunding für die
streitkräfte zur verfügung gestellt
werden so wie wir sehen in der ukraine
wo zum teil den streitkräften durch
sammeln von geld drohen angeschafft
werden die dann quasi von ihnen
eingesetzt werden und auf der anderen
seite natürlich militärische drohnen von
einem entsprechenden größe die dann auch
bewaffnet werden kann die aber natürlich
dann von staatlichen akteuren zum
beispiel im rahmen von zusätzlichen
lieferungen in das land kommen
sehen uns zuerst die russische modell an
die russische seite hat eine ganze reihe
von drohnen von der kasse ein sogar zwei
kleinere drohnen diese einsetzt aber
auch taktische drohnen wie zum beispiel
das modell vor post oder online sehen
dass wir hier sehen können
zusätzlich setzen sie auch größere
drohnen vom typ klasse 3 also
vergleichbar amerikanischen creator das
ist das russische modell orion es
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass es nicht
nur aufklären kann sondern es kann also
auch eine entsprechende bewaffnung
mitnehmen und die dann zielgerichtet zum
einsatz zu bringen
zusätzlich gibt es auch sogenannte leute
in harmonischen also was die kamikaze
drohnen die von russischer seite
eingesetzt werden wie zum beispiel
dieses modell coupe de la wo wir wissen
dass es zum beispiel kiew schon
eingesetzt worden ist
die russische seite hat beim einsatz von
drohnen in den letzten jahren viel
erfahrung gesammelt nicht nur in syrien
sondern vor allem auch in der ukraine
hervorzuheben ist das jahr 2014 wo es
dazu gekommen ist dass russische drohnen
zum beispiel vom typ vor brust die
ukrainischen streitkräfte aufgeklärt
haben in grenznähe und dann gezielt
durch den einsatz von artillerie und
mehrfach raketenwerfern zum beispiel vom
typ b m 30 bekämpft haben interessant
auch der einsatz von der oberlahn 10
alles teil eines komplexes der
elektronischen kampfführung wo also
gezielt mit dieser drohne nachrichten
sprach versendet worden sind
als beispiel das hier anzusprechen ist
ist der einsatz von drohnen aufklärung
in kombination mit artilleriefeuer im
juli 2014 wo eine ukrainische brigade im
freien gelände durch den massiven
einsatz von artillerie und mehrfach
raketen davon zerschlagen worden ist im
raum celle mobiler mit sehr schweren
verlusten das hat natürlich dazu geführt
dass die ukrainische seite begonnen hat
aus diesen erfahrungen zu lernen und die
in den letzten jahren bis zum konflikt
umzusetzen die ukrainische seite hat es
eine reihe von modellen der klasse 1 und
2 sich beschafft und gerade in den
letzten wochen erleben wie auch viele
spenden oder anlieferungen von systemen
wie zum beispiel dieses system kontext
reach oder auch das system viktor
troicki für die ukrainische streitkräfte
zur verfügung gestellt worden ist
zusätzlich zu den bereits beschafften
klasse 1 und klasse zwei drohnen hat die
ukrainische seite auch dieses modell der
türkei die bayraktar geschafft die
bayraktar tp2 zeichnet sich dadurch aus
dass sie klein und kompakt ist und luft
boden raketen mit werden kann diese über
einen sprecher entfernung einsetzen kann
und raketen der
dlc oder gar beamte
es ist wichtig zu verstehen dass diese
bayraktar thronen bereits 2020 das erste
mal eingesetzt worden sind hier sehen
wir ein bild wo die ukrainische seite
damals gezeigt hat dass sie mit diesen
drohnen in der lage ist radarstation und
auf der krim zu beobachten ein jahr
später kam es dann zum ersten einsatz
dieser drohne wo eine artilleriestellung
in den separatisten gebeten durch eine
bayraktar beschossen worden sind und ein
beginn des konflikts nach dem 24 februar
wurde diese drohnen eingesetzt um ziele
auf russischer seite zu bekämpfen
interessant ist auch dass die
ukrainische seite sich leute munition
geschafft hat wie zb dieses modell aus
polen mit genannt dass die idee diese
drohne ist es quasi sich selbst in ein
ziel zu stürzen und dort sitzt der
störung zu verursachen der gefechtskopf
lässt es auch zu quasi panzerungen zu
durchschlagen
interessant wird die anlieferung von
derartigen modellen von seiten der nato
und der usa geben wir zwei modelle die
interessant sind das system switchblade
300 oder 600 das was sie sich in
zulieferung befindet vor allem für den
einsatz im raum darum was wo zurzeit
eher der kampf tobt bzw das zweite
system für nix gewusst wo man also auch
erwarten kann dass diese systeme
möglicherweise durchaus einen effekt auf
dem geschäftsfelder ziel
sehen wir uns nun zusammengefasst zehn
möglichkeiten ein niemand drohnen
einsetzen kann wie gehen wir mit der
ersten möglichkeit der klassische
einsatz zur aufklärung hier ein beispiel
einer russischen drohen in diesem fall
eingesetzt sondern im tschetschenischen
kämpfern mario pohl diese drohne dafür
vom typ sa
unterstützt die russischen streitkräfte
bei der eroberung indem sie ein
verbessertes lagebild den angriffen
soldaten gibt
die zweite möglichkeit ist es aufgrund
der von der drohne flogen daten gezielt
artillerie einzusetzen hier könnte man
zum beispiel einsetzen endfassung
gesteuerte hat die munition sowie das
von ukrainischer seite passiert dass die
drohne erklärten ziel auf und die
artillerie granate schlägt gesteuert was
sind dieses ziel ein unter umständen
auch sogar mit entsprechender
beleuchtung von seiten patrone an
drohnen können hier eine ganze reihe von
modell eingesetzt werden wie zum
beispiel auch diese handelsüblichen
magic pro systeme
die nächste möglichkeit wäre wie schon
bereits erwähnt die drohne einzusetzen
zur aufklärung für artillerie systeme
die eine flächenwirkung erzählen wie zum
beispiel in diesem fall die russische
post ohne die daten generiert auf deren
basis dann eine artillerie batterie zum
beispiel diese 21 19 geschütze ein ziel
bekämpfen können
die vierte möglichkeit wäre die drohne
auch zu beladen mit abwurf körpern so
wie sie zum beispiel sehr erfolgreich
vom ukrainischen spezialkräften in den
ersten wochen des konflikts eingesetzt
worden sind da wurden also multikulti
copter verwendet sie wurden mit der
aproz mitteln da sehen und es war also
möglich mit einem entsprechenden
durchschlag leistung sogar mechanisierte
ziele zu zerstören
eine weitere möglichkeit wäre keine
drohne zu verwenden die mit rotoren
ausgestattet ist sondern eine flächen
tone mit auch entsprechende zuladung die
es möglich macht auch gezielt angriffe
zu fliegen wie zum beispiel dieses
ukrainische modell mit 22 von denen wir
aufgrund von dokumentierten abstürze
müssen dass auch die ukrainische seite
sie einsetzt
die ukraine haben auch selbst noch
zusätzlich weitere munition
entwickelt zb diese erste 35 womit wir
bei der sechsten ausgabe werden dass die
drohne stürzt sich selbst in das ziel
unterstützt das ziel was sie beim
einschlag mit der entsprechenden
durchschnittsleistung
die sind die möglichkeit des thronen
einsatzes ist es drohnen systeme zu
verwenden um mit der mitgeführten luft
boden raketen über hohe distanz ziele zu
bekämpfen ein beispiel ist die genannte
bayraktar throne die raketen mit führt
die entfernung zum einsatz gebracht
werden können der vorteil ist dass diese
drohne dadurch nicht so leicht erkannt
werden kann weil sie sehr klein und
kompakt ist und einen geringen radler
querschnitt hat und der einschlag der
rakete überraschend erfolgt wenn man es
nicht in der lage ist die entsprechend
rechtzeitig zu detektieren
eine weitere möglichkeit des drohnen
einsatzes ist es eine drohne zu
verwenden um ein bestimmtes ziel über
längere zeit aufzuklären und dann
präzise zu schlagen zu können als
beispiel hier diese russische und ohne
die sich dazu eignet mit den luft boden
raketen ein
hochwertiger target anzugreifen indizien
dafür gab es beim einsatz waren dieser
drohnen im raum kiew wo wir gesehen
haben dass der organische präsident
mehrmals vor sogenannten blue screen
aufgetreten ist was ein indiz dafür ist
dass er nicht ins freie gegangen ist
weil hohe gefahr bestand durch diese
russischen drohnen gezielt ausgeschaltet
zu werden
eine weitere möglichkeit des einsatzes
ist das eine drohne als plattform zu
verwenden hier wieder ein russisches
beispiel die drohne erol ansehen
fungiert wie ein fliegender handymast
als teil des komplexes für elektronische
kampfführung rb 341 das heißt handys
werden sich jetzt wohl in der massen in
die drohne ein und die drohne kann dazu
genutzt werden gezielt entsprechende
nachrichten zu versenden
die nächste möglichkeit des drohnen
einsatzes ist der einsatz im schwarm
hier ist es in der definition so dass
wenn der schwarm miteinander
kommuniziert wir tatsächlich von einem
intelligenten schwarm sprechen wenn
jedoch mehrere drohnen gleichzeitig
eingesetzt werden es dazu kommt dass vor
allem die masse einer ziel möglich macht
zu erreichen in der ukraine können wir
möglicherweise erwarten dass diese
switchblade drohnen oder diese phoenix
groß tonen in eine hohe zahl eingesetzt
werden und damit positiv gegnerischen
abwehr systeme auf russischer seite
überfordert werden und diese drohnen
dann einen entsprechenden effekt auf dem
gefechtsfeld erzielen der einsatz von
vielen kamikaze thronen in schwärmen
lässt natürlich die frage entstehen ob
der panzer auch in zukunft noch seine
bedeutung auf dem gefechtsfeld hat
tatsächlich ist es so dass der panzer
der einzige möglichkeit darstellt
gelände in besitz zu nehmen in einer
kombination aus panzerung voller kraft
und beweglichkeit möchte dies auch in
zukunft erfüllen können muss aber
geschützt werden gegen diese bedrohungen
das bedeutet dass mechanisierte verbände
entsprechend am marsch zum angriffsziel
geschützt werden müssen wie auch in der
vergangenheit die besonderheit besteht
darin das kamikaze thronen sehr kleine
radler querschnitte haben das heißt alle
mitfahrenden systeme der abwehr müssen
in der lage sein die drohnen trotzdem zu
erkennen und entsprechend bewirken zu
können kommen viele drohnen gleichzeitig
zum einsatz müssen die abo systeme so
gestaltet sein dass diese vielen drohnen
entsprechend bekämpft werden können dann
hat der panzer auch in zukunft seine
bedeutung als ein beispiel habe ich hier
das tor im 1 system der russischen seite
genommen problem wir auch wissen dass es
sich in der ukraine einsatz befindet
dieses system wurde aufgrund erfahrungen
der russischen seite in syrien
nachgerüstet um gerade gegen kleine
drohnen eingesetzt werden zu können
zum schluss möchte ich ihnen dieses bild
zeigen es zeigt eine russische online 10
drohne die von ukrainischer seite
erbeutet worden ist und wo in diesem
video kurz dargestellt wird die bauteile
die verwendet worden sind von russischer
seite
im video erkennt man dass die bauteile
sehr einfach gestaltet sind und im
wesentlichen aus dem zivilen bereich
stammen und nicht aus dem militärischen
bereich hier kann man in die eine oder
andere richtung argumentieren dass eine
ist natürlich dass aufgrund des
umstandes dass es keine militärischen
bauteile sind die qualität
möglicherweise nicht diese auch was die
militärische bauteile wir sind drohnen
verbaut sind haben die andere seite ist
aber dass diese drohne zeigt dass es
sehr leicht ist mit handelsüblichen
produkten also zum beispiel einem
chinesischen motor oder auch bauteilen
die man im modellflug berg bekommt sehr
rasch eine sehr leistungsfähige
militärische drohnen zu erzeugen wenn
wir jetzt nur noch die möglichkeit von
sanktionen denken so scheint es klar
dass derartige drohnen sehr schwer mit
sanktionen bekämpft werden können weil
die bauteile ja überall auf dem markt
beschafft werden können damit bin ich am
ende meiner präsentation sollten sie ein
weiteres interesse haben an der
drohnenkrieg sie und was das bedeutet
vor allem für das volk gericht so
empfehle ich ihnen mein buch robotik was
ich bedanke mich für das zuhören und bis
zum nächsten mal